Okay, we have another simple concept question being asked today.
So which of the following statements about factors of safety is true about soils near
occupied structures?
1.
The factor of safety against soil heave is less than the factor of safety against rotational
failure for a stable slope.
2.
The factor of safety against soil heave is greater than the factor of safety against
for a stable slope.
3.
The factor of safety against soil heave is the same as the factor of safety against rotational
failure for a stable slope.
4.
The factor of safety against soil heave and the factor of safety against rotational
failure for a stable slope will depend upon their own calculations for each case.
And what we can see here is that number two is going to be the correct answer.
Typically, soil heave receives a factor of safety of somewhere between 4 and 5,
whereas rotational failure for a stable soil will have a factor of safety closer to 1.5.
And usually, the soil heave is higher due to the fact that the heave analysis contains a lot of inherent inaccuracies in the calculations
that need to be accounted for.
So the factor of safety is more conservative there to guard against any unknowns.
And that's really it for this problem.
Not all concept questions are able to be searched for in the reference manual,
but if you can find those equations, you might be able to find something about the factors of safety.
Otherwise, just do your best with these and don't beat yourself up if you don't know them.